vicki vale bruce wayne and what do you
do for a living
[Music]
welcome to your weekly tickets hot off
the success of invisible man
elizabeth moss and blumhouse are teaming
up on another psychological thriller
moss will produce and star in mrs march
based on the yet to be published novel
by virginia phyto
moss will play the titular character a
manhattan housewife who starts to lose
her grip on reality when she suspects
her novelist husband
based a revolting character in his
latest bestseller on her
and sticking with that genre the
mysterious new james 1 original horror
film malignant got a little tease from
star
annabelle wallace while doing promos for
the silencing wallace described
malignant as
a passion project for juan wallace told
the hollywood reporter
it's genre bending i think it's so brave
it's so
original malignant is completed and
would be in theaters right now
but it awaits a new release date due to
coronavirus
the silencing however is currently
available on fandango now
and voodoo while the upcoming movie
release schedule remains in flux
some of the biggest productions are back
in front of cameras the jurassic park
alums
sam neil and laura dern have been
sharing cheeky production photos on
their return to the franchise
jurassic world dominion the hat is back
the cast is back
movies uh uh find a way
and fresh off his recent 66th birthday
james cameron is back at work on the
four
avatar sequels yes four
his producer john landau shared photos
of cameron at work in the elaborate
avatar tanks
jurassic world dominion currently hits
theaters june 11 2021
and the first avatar sequel lands in
theaters december 16
2022
well it's almost time for dc fans to
come together virtually of course for
the 24-hour fandom happening
this saturday and with big announcements
planned from dc and warner brothers
films you
don't want to miss out so today we're
celebrating by highlighting fandango
now's
list of dc films so today i am joined by
editor-in-chief of heroic hollywood
umberto gonzalez because
who better to talk about superhero films
so
umberto what's your go-to dc film
recently
i discovered my my love again for the 89
batman that starred michael keaton it
came out on 4k
recently the transfer was gorgeous and
it brought me back to the time
which i feel was the launch of the
modern superhero movie era which is the
89 batman but also of note
seeing how keaton was in the role and
keeping in mind
that he's in fact going to play the same
role again
in the upcoming ezra miller the flash
movie so it felt like a good opportunity
to catch up again with keaton get
re-familiarize myself with the movie
also nostalgia purposes it was a great
time in my life it was summer 89 it was
batman
everywhere that you couldn't like you
couldn't avoid it it was on merchandise
it was on books it was
it was everywhere but uh it's a good
it's a it's a great movie the
documentaries on the 4k are great
and yeah it's just it's good to
refamiliarize myself with what keaton
batman is doing so that way when we
catch up with him in the years to come
we see what he's been up to is he your
favorite batman
my favorite batman cinematically has to
be ben affleck's uh batman oh wow
okay cool yeah no i i totally understand
that warehouse fight
alone just just did it for me you know
that's the batman i grew up reading in
the late 80s
around the time the 89 batman came out i
respect a a training scene that he got a
training scene
affleck yeah he got to lift tires and
stuff so
exactly uh but now the dc
fan dome that's coming up uh you've
hosted a few panels can you tell us kind
of what to expect from this
basically i host a panel on comic book
grading
like as you see above you like i have
those are graded uh books on the first
appearances of bane
uh i think there's it's exciting they
probably saw what comic-con did
and then said to themselves what can we
do that's better so from what i
understand
their panels will be similar to like a
comic con experience where you have a
host like myself talking but then it's
intercut with footage
like so they they're putting them
they're making a major production out of
it
so i would expect to see footage from
suicide squad
i think the batman like matt reeves was
very excited to be a part of it
and uh maybe some more casting details
on black adam
it's a very exciting like that's part of
the insider verse so
i'm excited to see not only the panels
but what kind of uh
what kind of footage they show the key
is though you got to watch it because
then the panels will disappear in 24
hours they're only available online for
24 hours
oh who's gonna ask about that oh no
you got oh you got the rumor on yeah you
only be available to watch it with for a
24-hour period
before it disappears back into the
multiverse oh my god
are there any like long shot guesses
that you have of something that might
show up
well jason momoa is showing up so i
would presume
he's probably previewing some aquaman
stuff
maybe not like footage but like maybe
what the what the next movie is going to
be about or maybe a villain or even a
plot line or something
you know you've got gaga though him dc
doesn't have anything aquaman related
for like at least another year
so he's there for a reason so hopefully
he comes out with something aquaman
sequel related we're gonna see some
stuff from the uh
the upcoming suicide squad game right i
think the game
but for sure the movie i think james
gunn on his personal twitter profile
said he was excited to show us some
stuff
uh and the movie yeah the movie's on
schedule and stuff so
we might see some maybe a minute or two
of footage like i kept like the way they
used to do a comic con so i'm excited
about that
man i would love to see some suicide
squad footage i just
i want to get a taste of what it's what
it's going to be you know yeah me too
absolutely all right well uh thank you
so much umberto where can people find
you
you can find me on twitter at el mayimbe
on instagram at amber gonzalez and
heroichollywood.com
also i cover the
fanboybeatforthewrap.com as well sick
dude well thank you so much for coming
on the show i appreciate it
thank you for having me alright thanks
[Applause]
and if you're looking for some other
brand new superhero film recommendations
here are some you can check out
the army thought the experiment was a
failure
but their drug didn't work but it just
took a little time to turn you into
in deathstroke knights and dragons slade
wilson leads two lives
one is the relentless killer known as
deathstroke and the other as a dedicated
family man
when these worlds collide the killer and
slave must fight to save his loved ones
as well as what remains of himself with
his soul torn apart and his young son
held captive
deathstroke will have to atone for the
sins of his past to fuel the battles of
his future
and also available to watch at home on
sunday after fandome has wrapped up
superman man of tomorrow i don't want
him to feel different
he is different he lifted a tractor with
one finger martha
whoever put him in that ship had no idea
or care for how dangerous a world they
were sending them to
superman man of tomorrow takes place
during the man of steel's early years
and the daily planet hires an
intern named clark kent as clark begins
his training he must go above and beyond
the call of his regular duties
to defend the city of metropolis from
the likes of lobo and parasite
the film stars alexandra d'addario ryan
hurst and darren chris
alright well that's it for today check
out that full list of dc films there's a
link below and let us know which one's
your favorite i'm kale and i'll see you
next time